let's bring some breaking news sky news
understands that ovo energy the uk's
third biggest gas and electricity
supplier is to axe a quarter of its
workforce as part of a restructuring
aimed at saving costs amid the deepening
industry crisis the company could
announce details of its plans as soon as
tomorrow our city editor mark kleinman
has the story what are the details there
mark
yeah that's right and uh over energy
which is as you say is britain's the
biggest
supplier we'll announce tomorrow this
redundancy program i understand it
equates to about 1700 jobs out of a
total workforce at ovo of
6200 so it's a very significant program
of job losses and will be interpreted as
a sign of the company's efforts to
control costs more efficiently during
this deepening energy sector crisis i
also understand that oboe which has
about four and a half million customers
will announce alongside news of these
job losses that it plans to increase
minimum staff pay to 12 pounds an hour
uh that it will bring all customer
facing jobs back to the uk from overseas
and that it's opening a new training
academy in glasgow it's been a pretty
awful week for ovo uh whose founder
stephen fitzpatrick apologized after it
sent an email to customers uh you might
recall recommending that they do star
jumps or couple their pets in order to
keep warm during the cold winter months
this restructuring and as follows the
collapse of uh more than two dozen
energy suppliers since august the
largest of which was bulb
with 1.7 million customers and with the
expectation that more are set to follow
in the coming weeks